orlando yoyo est entré dans la compagnie
de jésus en 1966 il allait prononcer ses
derniers voeux quand les événements se
sont produits le 23 mai 1976 dans un
bidonville de buenos aires est en
argentine
un escadron de la mort du régime
militaire fait irruption et embarque
iorio et son ami jésuite france génique
les deux jésuites seront torturés
enchaîné pieds et mains encagoulées
pendant cinq mois à la sinistre école de
mécanique navale 24 octobre suivant
il sont drogués et abandonné dans un
champ en banlieue de buenos aires s
[Musique]
un an plus tard exilé à rome orlando
iorio écrit une longue lettre ou dans le
menu détail
il raconte son histoire une histoire
troublante qui jette une zone d'ombré
sur celui qui était à l'époque son
supérieur orgue et mario bergoglio
devenu depuis peu le pape françois
[Musique]
nous sommes en mars 2013 au moment du
conclave à rome personne n'a vu venir le
cardinal argentin est très vite on
comprend que c'est un moment historique
le cardinal bergoglio est le premier
pape d'amérique latine
le premier qui vient du sud est le
premier 6,8 à devenir pape bruxelles
[Musique]
peu de journalistes connaissaient le
cardinal bergoglio dans les jours qui
suivent son élection on découvre qu'il
préfère la modestie la simplicité
il peut faire les transports en commun
la limousine et puis on raconte que du
temps où il était cardinal archevêque de
buenos aires s ils fréquentaient les
bidonvilles
on le surnomme le pape des pauvres vous
êtes ici dans la ville avec un quartier
de misère d'un gobelet o et venait
régulièrement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la popularité du pape
françois ne fait aucun doute mais il y à
des tâches dhombres dans l'histoire est
encore aujourd'hui certains
s'interrogent
quel rô le jeu satie joué pendant la
violant dictature militaire des années
soixante dix
où
oh
[Musique]
orgue et mario bergoglio est un fils
d'immigrants italiens
il a été levé à buenos aires s est il a
dit c'est sa ville et c'est ici dans ce
confessionnal de l'isan osé qu'à 17 ans
bergoglio à une révélation
il veut devenir prêtre à 22 ans il
intègre la compagnie de jésus
à 33 ans il est ordonné prêtre et trois
ans plus tard à 36 ans seulement il
devient le patron et les jésus
d'argentine lui doivent obéissance
mais nous sommes en 1973 l'argentine est
sur le point de basculer dans la
violence et la dictature qui mènera une
lutte sans merci au communisme le jeune
bergoglio avait t-il ce qu'il fallait
pour faire face à la réalité de ces
années là dans ce pays qui était une
véritable poudrière
mais justement à cette même époque
l'église catholique d'amérique latine
est traversé par de puissants courants
français on parle beaucoup de la
théologie de la libération
certains veulent changer l'église se
tourner vers les pauvres non pas pour
assister à leur calvaire
mais pour changer le monde avec eux
aller vers les pauvres pas son nom pour
parler des pauvres mais vivre et des
dames accompagner ces pauvres fortuna de
manille mathier sociologue en argentine
c'est une référence quand il est
question de religion et de société
et il a été un élite personnel d'orlando
iorio il dit c'est vivre dans la même
situation sociale politique économique
que ces gens là alors la seule façon
c'est aller vivre dans cette île fait la
communauté de vie chrétienne dans cette
vidéo mobile à buenos aires est les 6,8
orlando yoyo fran djelic et louise du
rhône à terre à cette vision de la
théologie de la libération il s'installe
dans le quartier de baho florès un
bidonville de buenos aires est pour
vivre avec les pauvres
une expérience qui ne fera jamais
l'unanimité au contraire à l'intérieur
même de l'église
on se questionne on les associe à la
gauche radicale et pour certains c'est
tout simplement trop
c'est ce que raconte frangélik dans un
livre qu'il a publié pour la première
fois en 1994
bon nombre de personnes ne voyaient pas
d'un bon oeil notre présence dans les
bidonvilles
elle considérait notre présence dans ce
quartier de misère comme soutient la
guérilla elles ont alors envisagé nous
dénoncer comme terroriste mais nous
savions d'où venait le vent et qui était
responsable de cette diffamation
je suis allé trouver cet homme et je lui
ai dit qu'ils jouaient avec notre vie
de qui le frère janyk parle-t-il
parle-t-il de son supérieur bergoglio
son collègue hollando iorio n'a aucun
doute son récit recoupe parfaitement
celui de son ami janyk en décembre 1975
compte tenu des rumeurs selon lesquelles
je participais à la guérilla frères
janyk a de nouveau parlé au père
bergoglio leber bergoglio a reconnu la
gravité de la situation et promis de
faire taire ces rumeurs au sein de la
communauté jésuite
il a aussi promis de témoigner aux
militaires de notre innocence
le frère janyk lui à garde un souvenir
amer de tout ça
selon des déclarations ultérieures faite
par un officier et d'après 30 documents
que j'ai eu plus tard en main il ne
faisait aucun doute que cet homme
n'avait pas tenu sa promesse et avait
fait de fausses déclarations aux
militaires
ces frictions vont durer des mois
et puis en février 1976 revenant de rome
le père bergoglio à un message pour
janick et iorio le message vient des
plus hautes autorités jésuites
l'expérience des bidonvilles c'est
terminé et c'est sans appel
le cardinal bergoglio n'a pas souvent
parler de ces événements publics en fait
très rarement
en 2010 il s'est confié au journal et
silvio roubine quelques pages de cet
entretien sont consacrés aux rôles de
bergoglio pendant la période de la
dictature
pour tout vous dire ces prêtres étaient
en train de monter une congrégation
religieuse
le supérieur général d'alors le père a
regroupé leur a dit qu'ils devaient
choisir entre la communauté dans
laquelle ils vivaient et la compagnie de
jésus et il leur a ordonné de quitter la
compagnie les premiers ciel à l'époque
s'est il dit non ça c'est pas
l'expérience catholique ça c'est pas une
espèce et nexpress chrétien ça c'est
plus un expérience politique et sociale
que je suis tu
c'était cinq jours seulement avant que
les militaires ne renversent le régime
d'isabelle perrin livrés à eux mêmes
la situation des trois jésuites de baho
flores devient particulièrement
inquiétant un an plus tard en exil
orlando yoyo décrit la suite le matin du
23 mai deux cents militaires ont
débarqué et ont paralysé le bidonville
et sont entrés chez nous ils ont saisi
des papiers et des documents ils ont
arrêté huit jeunes qui enseignait la
catéchèse
ils nous ont fait prisonniers frères
janyk et moi même
ils seront torturés pieds et mains liés
encagoulées pendant cinq mois dans les
locaux de la sinistre école supérieure
de mécanique de la marine
louise turron le troisième 18 aura plus
de chance il aura échappé aux militaires
en fuyant et bicyclette pour gagner la
compagnie ni tendre leurs gains luis
farah connaissait bien huriaux il
participé ensemble à des expériences
pastorales à l'époque l'interprétation
que lucho seul écueil au pardon et
effectivement est en situation de
production leur militari de la lincoln
ou la ceni elle comme la garante à
blanka bara gaye sa tourelle un énorme
morceau du casse-tête se trouve ici
orlando yoyo et fran djelic
ont-ils été balancé par leurs propres
communautés religieuses par le père
bergoglio
jusqu'à sa mort en l'an 2000 rolando
urios tentera de résoudre l'énigme
aujourd'hui c'est sa soeur graciela qui
poursuit le combat de son frère pour la
vérité à laquelle il n'a jamais eu droit
dit elle j'en ai la certitude ils ont
quitté les jésuites parce que période
guillaud a mis beaucoup de pression sur
eux ils se sont retrouvés sans évêque
pour les super parce que bergoglio avait
écrit des rapports désobligeants sur eux
ils se sont retrouvés absolument sans
protection et le 23 mai 1976 ils ont été
kidnappés raciale a eu lieu dit qu'elle
a rencontré le père bergoglio à
plusieurs reprises elle a voulu le
confronter à propos des rapports
désobligeants qu'il aurait fait circuler
ou sujet de son frère
orlando j'ai rencontré trois fois
bergoglio en 1976 pour essayer de
libérer mon frère la plus passionnelle
et durant l'une de ces rencontres il
m'avait dit j'écris un bon rapport sur
you d'ailleurs je vais vous le montrer
il s'est retourné comme s'il allait
prendre le dossier mais il ne m'a jamais
rien montré non meurtre la mema
recommandé plutôt d'être prudente parce
que disent-ils
je risquais d'être kidnappé à mon tour
l'astra italienne à la cave
mais les militaires avaient ils besoin
du signal d'un prêtre pour arrêter
torturer deux jésuites dans les
bidonvilles
le père bergoglio était le patron des
jésuites en argentine mais quelle
influence avait il réellement ni
cardinal il était simplement ils
n'avaient aucune influence sur la
conférence des évêques d'argentine du
pour répondre à votre question je ne
crois pas que berg au lieu et les
complices des militaires compris cidade
alta bulletins dans le livre de ces
lieux robin dago guillou se présente
comme un noble religieux qui aurait
sauvé des vies en cachant des gens va
chercher par des militants
nous nous sommes démenés comme des fous
pour faire libérer les deux jésuites
raconte le cardinal bergoglio à silvio
robin
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu avec l'âge que
j'avais et le peu de relation que je
comptais ces quelques mots du cardinal
bergoglio ressemble à un aveu il n'avait
que 36 ans à l'époque mais avait-il la
maturité l'expérience politique
nécessaires pour être l'homme de la
situation
dans cette crise exceptionnelle et
violente
[Musique]
à l'époque les militaires menaient de
nombreuses rafles torture est tout ce
qu'il soupçonnait de subversion ou de
sympathie avec la guérilla
trente mille personnes sont disparues
quand la dictature a pris fin des procès
ont été intentés contre les militaires
et une commission a tenté de faire la
lumière sur les événements leur pari
janice joliot décrire accompagnant ce
n'est qu'en 2010 34 ans après les
événements qu'elle cardinal bergoglio
acceptera de répondre aux questions de
la justice argentine et encore la
commission devra se déplacer dans les
locaux de l'archevêché le témoignage de
horgues et mario bergoglio va susciter
beaucoup d'intérêt parce que depuis
bergoglio est devenu archevêque de bruno
crs et cardinal princes de l'église qui
avait à la chose la commission cherche à
comprendre qui était la source des
rumeurs qui ont mené à l'enlèvement de
yoyo et j'allais à l'époque où il
travaillait dans les bidonvilles dit
qu'elle n'a pas une partie couleurs
bertholio répond qu'il y avait
effectivement des gens des différents
secteurs de la société et de l'église
qui n'est même pas que des religieux
travail dans les bidonvilles ça la
commission le savez ce que le procureur
veut ce sont des noms qui entretenait de
tels propos à l'endroit de yoyo et
janick nourrir les pilot est propre et
il est mou qui partageaient pas ses
investigations et à l'université
oui des récitals à grenoble et à plaisir
à luna agout même l'accompagner avec
chose me mbres de l'accompagner exit
membres l'église catholique a killer qui
a stipulé annuaire des pectoraux qui y
poussent à vannes
aucun parti n était pas sur amiens toha
lé travail qu on la forme de travaux et
sacerdotales djallit julio il est encore
tina min au général athor le sas et
rotin et eni annonce option par canal
leur parti qui les secteurs et diverses
traversal fiable arts a cédé 6 à ces
publics à la loggia empilables ammann
est le secteur où l'appareil est triste
mine contrite au rouleau vie pour
halloween cardinal à leur nom pour qui
la loue mon jeu comme tels que nous les
lave est important c'est un échantillon
nos questions d'innovation
sinon les stylos des quais si l'indicé
nasdaq perd aux atteintes à l'art et six
civils un dandy et août a évoqué le
retard à une portance à nous sentir si
nos peurs l'accusation alors que trois
caravanes dont le port est et un sourd
ce qui ressortira du témoignage du
cardinal bergoglio c'est à quel point sa
vision des événements tranche avec celle
de yoyo et jolie qu il y à une autre
tâche d'ombré autour de la dictature
argentine et du rôle du clergé
pendant la dictature les militaires ont
littéralement volé des enfants et des
nouveau nés de mères qui l'ont assassiné
500 enfants auraient été volés et donner
à des gens influents des militaires des
policiers
le père bergoglio le savent-ils en 2010
quand la justice argentine demande au
cardinal bergoglio camp at il appris que
des enfants vis du politique
le cardinal demeure assez récemment
répond-t-il d'abord au procureur pour
ensuite précisé peut-être au moment du
procès contre la junte militaire
or ces procès ont débuté en 1985
geste-là de la quadra répète sur tous
les toits que le cardinal était au
courant depuis bien plus longtemps
en fait depuis 1977 et stella de la
quadra a perdu plusieurs membres de sa
famille sous la dictature dont elena qui
était enceinte de 5 mois lorsqu'elle a
été kidnappé désespéré la famille a fait
appel aux plus hautes autorités jésuites
à rome pour qu'on les aide à retrouver
l'ena le père général a loupé ensuite
demandé à bergoglio qu'ils rencontrent
berthod de la quadra le père de la
famille
plutôt que d'enquêter lui-même sur la
disparition d'elena d'agde olio demande
par écrit à un évêque monseigneur pcci
de recevoir roberto de la quadra il est
monté hier qu'une tape nbc par cette
filière que la famille apprend qu elle n
en est morte qu'elle a accouché en
captivité et que le bébé a été donné à
quelqu'un d'influent hors de portée
oublié l'enfant
en 2010 dans une procédure plutôt
exceptionnel le cardinal bergoglio
accepte de répondre par écrit à 33
question de la justice argentine sur
cette affaire dans ce témoignage
bergoglio reconnaît avoir reçu roberto
de la quadra mais ne se souvient pas des
détails de l'entretien à la question
numéro 13 on demande le cardinal
bergoglio si monsieur de la quadra lui a
mentionné qu'il recherchait sa fille
disparue et qu'elle était enceinte
réponse du cardinal il m'a dit que sa
fille avait été kidnappé je ne me
rappelle pas qu'il me dit qu'elle était
enceinte à la question numéro 15
la justice revient la charge et demande
aux cardinals si parmi les membres de la
famille de la quadra qu'on lui a demandé
de rechercher s'il y avait un garçon ou
une fille nouveau né
le cardinal répond je ne me rappelle pas
de ce fait référez-vous à la réponse que
j'ai donnée à la question 13 autrement
dit le cardinal soutient qu'il ne savait
pas qu'elle était enceinte
il ne l'aurait appris que des années
plus tard on est là de la quadra n'en
croit rien pour l bergoglio devait
savoir dès 1977 que des enfants étaient
voilés par les militaires pour l
bergoglio ma
[Musique]
c'était en 1977 et stella a fait de
cette triste histoire
le combat de sa vie elle est la fille
d'une des cofondatrices de
l'organisation des grands mères de la
place de mai créé en 1977
place de mai est parvenu à identifier
108 enfants volés
des centaines d'autres manquent toujours
à l'appel
aujourd'hui c'est estela de carlotto qui
en est la présidente
elle aussi a perdu un enfant mais de la
dictature
alors bergoglio à l'époque pouvait-il
ignorer tous ses vols d'enfants surtout
après le cas de la famille de la quadra
[Musique]
oui il le savait bon on peut peut-être
dire qu'il ignorait l'existence d'un
plan systématique de vol de bébés c'est
autre chose mais que des enfants étaient
volés ça il ne pouvait pas ne pas le
savoir
j'ai du mal à croire qu'ils ne le savais
pas et il est notamment le travail de
stella de carlotto a maintes fois été
saluée notamment en 2003 lorsque les
nations unies lui ont remis le prix des
droits de l'homme la présidente des
grands mères de la place de mai s'est
rendu récemment à rome pour rencontrer
bergoglio le nouveau pape françois elle
avait une idée en tête lui demander
d'ouvrir les archives de l'église
l'argentine sur cette période
controversée
le pape lui a répondu compter sur moi
évidemment c est la historia bergoglio
évidemment l'histoire de bergoglio
antérieur et sa capote et ne s'efface
pas l'histoire ne peut pas s'effacer ne
peut pas s'oublier ni soldats mais il
faut s'en tenir à sa vie actuelle celle
du pacs est apposé son visa
donnons lui l'opportunité de réparer son
silence de parler et de nous aider avec
les hameaux cela oportunidades avait pas
pour va lui accorder un certain temps
tout en continuant à insister malgré pas
à des soucis les uns sur il par câble et
par là que nous a joué les grands mères
de la place de mai veut avoir accès aux
archives de l'église
on comprend existe-t-il des traces des
correspondances des documents qui
permettraient de comprendre le rôle de
l'hélice et du père bergoglio dans cette
troublante époque
à rome le directeur des archives de la
compagnie de jésus ne perds ma kwarta a
refusé de répondre à nos questions et
les plus hautes autorités jésuites nous
ont répondu qu'ils ne pouvaient rien
pour nous toutes les archives depuis
1939 à rome sont fermées au public
[Musique]
ce témoignage du cardinal bergoglio
n'est peut-être pas particulièrement
convaincant mais la justice argentine
elle n'a trouvé aucun reproche à lui
faire
non temps beau coffret part il ya des
évêques qui étaient de mèche avec la
dictature et il y en avait d'autres qui
étaient avec nous contre la dictature en
adolfo pérez esquivel a lui aussi été
jetée en prison et torturés
il a reçu le prix nobel de la paix en
1981 il sait qu'il y à des membres du
clergé qui étaient de mèche avec les
militaires est à 1000 nouveaux acquis au
prix fort un complice s il y a su qu'ils
allaient jusqu'à justifier la torture la
mort les justifier tout ce que faisait
l'armée parce qu'il luttait contre le
communisme international
ils étaient des oppresseurs
le prix nobel de la paix croit fermement
en l'innocence de bergoglio d'ailleurs
c'est lui qui signe la préface d'un
livre qui sera bientôt publié en italie
et qui soutient que le père bergoglio
était à la tête d'un réseau de contacts
pour soutenir ceux qui s'opposent à la
dictature
ce que je dis c'est que bergoglio n'a
pas collaboré avec la dictature
il a fait ce qu'il a pu comme d'autres
membres du clergé
tous n'étaient pas disposés à se battre
contre elle
c'est vrai mais on ne peut pas dire
qu'il ne fût pas courageux
orlando iorio a été tourmenté jusqu'à sa
mort en 2000 sa soeur graciela soutient
qu orlando n'a jamais obtenu la vérité
sur ce qu'ils ont vécu
nous nous sommes donc tournés vers les
deux compagnons d'orlando qui sont
toujours en vie d'abord fin djelic comme
orlando frein djelic a longtemps était
très préoccupée par le rôle de bergoglio
dans tout ce qui leur est arrivé
mais lorsqu'en mars 2013
bergot bio est élu pape j'ai les
publient un communiqué de presse dans
lequel il dit s'être réconcilié avec les
événements et le père bergoglio et dans
une phrase énigmatique
il dit qu'il ne peut pas commenter le
rôle de bergoglio à l'époque le
communiqué de jal est qu'à piquer la
curiosité des médias
cinq jours plus tard nouveau communiqué
de presse orlando iorio et moi dit-il
n'avons pas été dénoncée par le père
bergoglio ne pas les avoir dénoncés
c'est une chose mais quel rôle dagogo at
il joué dans cette lugubre page
d'histoire que c'était passé pour que
frank schleck change radicalement de
version il a 85 ans il se trouve
aujourd'hui dans un monastère en
allemagne il nous a bien fait comprendre
qu'il ne parlera plus de ces années là
[Musique]
il ne reste que l'autre jésuites louise
turron qui a échappé aux militaires le
23 mai 1976
on racontait qu'il vivait à paris ou
encore en bolivie nous avons plutôt
retrouvé sa trace ici dans une lointaine
banlieue de buenos aires s louise du
rhône a défroqué mais participe encore
et des quêtes des chaises tous les
samedi nous at on dit eh bien le samedi
suivant
nous sommes revenus la méfiance ici
était palpable et de fait ce jour là
nous pourrons ne se montrera pas
dans une brève conversation téléphonique
durant nous dit qu'il ne veut plus
jamais parler de tout ça même si son
témoignage pourrait apporter un précieux
éclairage sur les événements luis duran
est devenu un fantôme 16 16 non
et voilà notre cema glaciers fin
aujourd'hui très peu par son parent sur
cette histoire va racheter
c'est pour lui c'est la personne qui va
parler c'est ce propos m
[Musique]
luis duran les franges alik sont des
témoins de premier ordre dans toute
cette histoire
alors pourquoi aujourd'hui refuse-t-il
de parler que racontent les archives de
la compagnie de jésus à rome et aussi à
buenos aires en argentine
que savait bergoglio aurait-il pu faire
davantage
que ce soit dans les rues de buenos
aires s ou dans cette villa de misère
que fréquentait le cardinal bergoglio ou
encore à l'autre bout du monde à saint
pierre de rome
la popularité du pape françois ne fait
aucun doute
certains le surnomment le pape des
pauvres c'est quand même paradoxal pour
un religieux qui a eu tant de mal avec
trois jésus est partie vivre avec les
pauvres pour changer le monde
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu avec l'âge que
j'avais et le plus de relation que je
comptais disait bergoglio
37 ans plus tard il reste des zones
d'ombré kita est l'histoire de
l'argentine de l'église et du père
pergaud clio devenu le pape françois
[Musique]